اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه ومن العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
ادوم الروسي يحذر من تزويد اوكرانيا
باسلحه الهجوميه ويؤكد انه سيؤدي لكارثه
عالميه
برلمان ايران يقول انه سيعتبر جيوش اوروبا
منظمات ارهابيه ردا على اي تصنيفا للحرس
الثوري
في ظل اجراءات امنيه مشدده الدبايبه يعقد
اجتماعا لوزراء الخارجيه العرب ومصر تتغيب
الاف المحتاجين يتظاهرون ضد الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وقرارات وزاريه مرتقبه
استجابه للضغوط
اهلا بكم البدايه من تطورات الحرب
الاوكرانيه حيث اكد الرئيس او رئيس مجلس
الدومه الروسي ان تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه
روسيا سيؤدي الى كارثه عالميه وحذر عبر
تلجرام
من تسليم الاسلحه والتي سيتم استخدامها
لشد ضربات على المدن ومحاوله الاستيلاء
على اراضينا وقال ان ذلك
سيقوض او يقود الى اجراءات الرد باستخدام
اسلحه اقوى واضاف انه من الضروري ان يدرك
السياسيون الاجانب الذين يتخذون مثل هذه
القرارات ان ذلك قد ينتهي بماساه عالميه
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان روسيا
ستواجه صعوبه في تنفيذ خطوطها لزياده عدد
قوات الجيش الى مليون ونصف المليون واضافت
ان الخطط بشان توزيعات الجيش تشير الى ان
القياده الروسيه ترى على الارجوح بشكل
كبير ان التهديد العسكريه التقليدي سيستمر
لعده سنوات بعد الحرب الحاليه مع اوكرانيا
تشهدوا مدينه مرينكا الواقعه غربي مقاطعه
دونيتك معارك ساخنه بين القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه والتي ما زالت تقام في بعض
الاحياء وتشير سلطات مقاطعه تنيتك
المواليه لموسكو ان المقاتلين الروس
سيطروا على الجزء الاكبر من مارينكا
ويسعون لوصل نفوذهم على اخر جيب من
المدينه لفتح الطرق امام الامدادات
العسكريه الروسيه فريق العربيه رصد الوضع
على خطوط المواجهه بين الطرفين في امريكا
الملتهبه بالمعاركي شمال غربيه مقاطعه
دانيت تنتقل الوفاه المقاتلين لارض
المعركه عبر حاملات الجنود سيرا على
الاقدام عبرناه الاوتيل المدينه الذي سيطر
عليه الجيش الروسي الهدفه هو الوصول الى
فنادق خط المواجهه الاول
هذه هي اثار المعارك الضاريه والساخنه
التي شهدتها هذه المدينه مدينه مارك خلال
الاشهر الماضيه حيث سيطر الجيش الروسي على
جزء كبير من هذه المدينه الحديث عن ثلثي
المدينه والمتبقي الثلث الاخير وهي
الابنيه الشاهقه سرنا كاسراب النمل حذرين
من الالغام بمحاذاه الجدران خشيه القناصه
في الثلث الاخير من المدينه يشتبك
المقاتلون بالبنادق وضعنا كاميرا على خوذه
مقاتل خلال عمليات الاقتحام التي تهدف
لاكمال السيطره على المدينه
يا الله
بعيد
[موسيقى]
على ضوء شمعه والدبابات تقصف موقعنا عبر
المسيرات
مر الدقائق الليل كالسنين بانتظار بزوق
الفجر على اثير الرشاقات الرصاص والصواريخ
ينفذ الجيش الروسي عمليات اقتحام في مدينه
ماركا الكائنه شمال الغرب مقاطعه دانيت
اليوم بالذات القوات الخاصه الروسيه تنفذ
عمليه اقتحام على هذه الابنيه ذات الخمسه
الطوابق نسمع اصوات الاشتباكات
بالاسلحه الخفيفه وايضا اصوات القصب
المدفعي والقصف بالدبابات لقناتي العربيه
والحدث رائد الاخضر
مع تزايد الضغوط الاوكرانيه والغربيه على
المانيا لتسليم دبابات اليوبار الاكيف
اعلن وزير الدفاع الالماني انه سيزور كيف
قريبا لبحث مساله التي تسليم تلك الدبابات
واكد ان بلاده مستعده لارسالها بالفعل
مشيرا الى انه على حوار وثيق مع الحلفاء
في الناتو ومع الولايات المتحده على وجه
الخصوص من اجل التوصل الى اتخذ قرار بشان
عمليه التسليم
وجهت دول البلطيق لاتفيه واستونيا
وليتوانيا دعوه المشتركه الى المانيا
لارسال دباباتها الرئيسيه الى اوكرانيا
ولمساعدتك في حربها ضد روسيا واعتبر وزير
خارجيه استونيا ان ارسال المانيا للدبابات
امر ضروري لمساعده اوكرانيا واعاده السلام
الى اوروبا بسرعه واشار الى ان برلين
عليها مسؤوليه خاصه في هذا الصدد وصدر
بيان دول البلطيق بعد يومين من فشل اجتماع
رمشتاين غرب المانيا في الاتفاقيه على
تسليم دبابات ثقيله من طراز ليوبارد
المانيه الصنع الى اوكرانيا او السماح
للدول الاخرى التي تملكها من فعل ذلك
نشير الى هذا العاجل مشاهدينا حيث يقول ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي لم يتم اتخاذ قرار بشان
ارسال دبابات ليوبارد ليوكرانيا بسبب موقف
المانيا اذن الاتحاد الاوروبي يؤكد بانه
لم يتم اتخاذ قرار لارسال الدبابات
ليوبارد لاوكرانيا بسبب موقف المانيا حتى
الان واجره روسيا تدريبات على نظامي دفاعا
الجوي في العاصمه موسكو في خطوه تعدل
الاولى منذ بدايه الحرب في فبراير الماضي
ضد اوكرانيا فيما افادت تقارير صحفيه ان
الانظمه الدفاعيه تعكس رغبه روسيا في
اعاده تامين نفسها
لاول مره منذ بدايه الحرب ضد اوكرانيا
روسيا تنفذ تدريبات تحاكي صد هجوم مفترض
على العاصمه موسكو قد يكون بالصواريخ او
بغارات تنفذها طائرات او مسيرات غربيه وان
كان بيان الدفاع الروسيه بررها بانها
للتصدي لهجوم مجموعه تخريبيه لعدو وهمي
تكمن اهميه التدريبات في انها تظهر مخاوف
روسيا من تعرض عاصمتها لهجمه مع وصول
اسلحه غربيه متقدمه لاوكرانيا خاصه بعد
تنفيذ هجمات على مناطق حدوديه روسيه مثل
بالجورد وتعرض قواعد عسكريه لهجمات
بمسيرات في عمق الروسي كما حدث في سيرته
وريزان فضلا عن مناطق ذمتها روسيا كالقرم
او لنيتها القيامه بعمليه عسكريه كبيره
تخشى ردا غربيا عليها حيث تتوقع دوائر
المخابرات الغربيه قيام روسيا بعمليه
واسعه في اوكرانيا واحتمال دخول بلاروسيا
معها
نشر انظمه دفاع جوي على اسطح ابنيه في
موسكو يراه البعض تناقضا مع التصريحات
الروسيه التي تؤكد ان مسار العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا يسير على ما يرام
وافق قطط وزاره الدفاع اما عن الاسباب
فيرجع مراقبون الامر للتخوف من امتلاك
اوكرانيا مسيرات يصل مداها الى 1000 كلم
ما يعني وصولها الى العاصمه الروسيه فيما
يرى البعض ان ذلك جزء من الدعايه الروسيه
وذلك عبر اظهار التهديد قد تتعرض له موسكو
لسكان العاصمه وتصوير اوكرانيا على انها
عدو لروسيا ما يزيد التعييده الشعبي لما
تسميها روسيا عمليتها العسكريه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى زياده نسبه التطوع
في القوات الروسيه هو ذلك هو حديث عن
تعبئه جديده قد تكون غير معلنه
قال بانه لديه امكانيه للوصول نحو الف
كيلومتر عبر المسيرات التي طورها ولذلك
يمكن ان تصل الى مدينه موسكو لكن كما قلت
ربما تكون روسيا تحضر الراي العام الروسي
من اجل معركه طويله وادعوا دفاعات جويه
على اسطح المنازل في موسكو مشهد قد يكون
الاول منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه وهو
المشهد الذي يستحضر تلك الاجواء ويهدد
بحرب كبيره الاكثر من ذلك تدريبات روسيا
كانت تهدف لحمايه منشات عسكريه بدواحي
موسكو بنشر منظومه اس 300 بهدف التصدي
لهجوم بالطائرات والصواريخ البالستيه وهي
التي تملكها حصرا دول النيترو
موسكو سبق وان تعرضت لهجوم في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وتمكن الاتحاد السوفيتي
من وقف تقدم دبابات هتلر نحو المدينه
حينها فهل نحن امام تصعيد جديد في الحرب
باوكرانيا قد يصل مداه الى العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو
اهلا بك معنا عبد الجواد هناك تصريحات
تخرج عن الدومه الروسيه حول التسليح
الغربي لاوكرانيا هل لك ان تجمل لنا ابرز
هذه التصريحات
مرحبا فاطمه بعد السلام نعم بالفعل يعني
يموت واعاده وتحدث تامن جديد عن ضروره عدم
تزويد الجانب الاوكراني باسلحه ثقيله وهذا
ما سيتسبب بايطاليا عمر الازمه وايطاله
فتره الصراعات المسلحه بين قوات موسكو
والقوات الاوكرانيه في الجنوب الاوكراني
على ما يبدو ان موسكو يعني اصبح تتحدث
بشكل مباشره بشكل
البيانات الاخيره قامت باجراء تدريبات من
العيار الثقيله على استخدام منظمات الدفاع
الجوي اس 3 وقد تم استخدامها من قبل
الخبراء لابد من الاشاره فاطمه الى ان عدد
الضباط الذين تم يعني تم تدريبهم على هذه
العمليه وصل الى مئه وخمسين بالمقابل طبعا
هناك 30 همم
30 من المعدات العسكريه الثقيله شاركت
ايضا في هذه التدريبات متوقع طبعا كما هو
منتظر لم يتم الاعلان رسميا عن قيام موسكو
بوضع انظمه للدفاع الجوي ووسط المدينه على
بعض الابناء العسكريه على بعض الاغنياء
الاداريه وغيرها من المباني لكن طبعا
نلاحظ فاطمه من
الاخبار ومن التقاطع الفيديو التي انتشرت
في الهاشم في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي هو
خاصه على تيليجرام بهذه العمليه ان
القياده الروسيه حسب قراءه بعض المحللين
العسكريين في البلاد والسياسيين تتجه نحو
حمايتي سمائي المدينه وحمايه سمائي
العاصمه وضواحيها منها جماعه المسيرات
الاوكرانيه هيا نعم بالفعل ايه 300 الحديث
عنها رسميا في موسكو طواحيها وبعض طبعا
انظمه الدفاع الجوي تم تثبيتها على بعض
الاغذيه في مدينه مصر
او اا عدم رغباتها في ارسال دبابات
ليوبارد الى اوكرانيا ودعوات دول البلطيق
ما ابرز ردود الفعل التي رصدتها من الداخل
حول ذلك وحول ايضا التقارب الالماني
الفرنسي الذي نشهده عبد الجواد
فاطمه يعني موسكو حتى هذه اللحظه ما زالت
ترى في وجهه نظر برلين وباريس حول الازمه
مع الاوكرانيه بانها تدعو لعدم الدخول في
صراع كبير ومسلح مع موسكو لذلك طبعا ملاحظ
بان موقف المانيا وموقف باريس من ارسال
هذه الدبابات الثقيله نحو الاراضي
الاوكرانيه قد يصعب ويصعد بالموقف كبيرا
العمل العسكريه كما نلاحظ تشهد الان
تصعيدا كبيرا من قبل موسكو خاصه بعد
الضربات التي شهدها همم جنوب الاوكراني في
بدايه هذا العام وطبعا ما قامت به موسكو
من ارسال فرقه فيها التي تحمل صواريخ
تشاركون نحو المحيط الاطلسي ما يسبب او ما
يوجه رساله مبطنه للغرب بان طبعا السواحل
الامريكيه قد تكون هدفا لهذه الصواريخ في
حال اشتعال الصراع بشكل كبير بينهم ولذلك
طبعا نلاحظ بان باريس كما
القراءه السياسيه في البلاد هي تاخذ موقف
المعني يعني بانهاء الازمه الاوكرانيا
نوعا ما بالرغم ان بالرغم من ان المانيا
وفرنساكومان يعني تقوم بفرض الكثير من
العقوبات على روسيا كما حال الجانب الغاز
كيف هي الاوضاع الميدانيه في دونيه كما
الانباء الوارده من هناك طبعا في التقرير
قبل دقيقه هي معارك من العيار الثقيل لكن
ما يلفت الانتباه اليوم طبعا بعد بيان
وزاره الدفاع الذي تحدث عن تحييد العشرات
من القوات الاوكرانيه المعارك وصلت الى
ذروتها في بعض المناطق في منطقه هي مناطق
سكنيه تقع في المنطقه الفاصله التي تسيطر
عليها موسكو سيطر عليها وهي قريبه من نهر
النيبر هناك الان طبعا يتم التقدم حسب
الروايه الروسيه من الجانب الروسي ومن
القوات الاحوال الاراضي الاوكرانيه سبعه
كيلو مترات تحدث تم الحديث عنها رسميا وما
تزال المعارك محترمه هناك بشكل كبير فاطمه
شكرا لك من موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد
[موسيقى]
اجتمعوا في المانيا وفشلوا بارسال دبابات
ثقيله الى اوكرانيا
اصابع اللون توجهت صوب المانيا التي قيل
انها رفضت ارسال دباباتها لاوبارد 2 الا
اذا قامت امريكا بذلك اولا
اوكرانيا
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه على تويتر التردد في
هذه المرحله يقتل المزيد من مواطننا
ودعوه لحلفائك الى التفكير بشكل اسرع
فيما تبررنسكي ان لا خيار اخر سواء ترسل
الدول الغربيه دبابات ثقيله الى بلاده
من جهه اخرى
لموقف المانيا الحذر في هذا الشان
البنتاجون انتقادات لاذعه لالمانيا
[موسيقى]
محبطون من موقف المانيا ويبدو انها لا
تعرف الفرق بين دباباتنا ودباباتها
السيناتور الامريكي
ايطالي مجلس الوزراء الفرنسيه الالماني
بعد تاجيل الاجتماع لاكثر من ثلاثه اشهر
هذا ودعم مجلس النواب الالماني الى احياء
التحالف الفرنسيه الالماني وتوقيع معاهده
الاليزي رغم الخلافات الاخيره بين باريس و
برلين
ايرانيون في مونتريال يطالبون بدعم دوليا
في طيران
قال رئيس البرلمان الايراني محمد باقر
بلاده ستعتبره جيوش الدول الاوروبيه
منظمات ارهابيه على حد وصفه وذلك ردا على
موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي من الحرس الثوري
الايراني
لوكاله تسنيم الايرانيه للانباء محاولات
الغرب ضد الحرس الثوري محكوم عليها بالفشل
ياتي ذلك بعد ما طالبه البرلمان الاوروبي
في قرار تبناه مجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي
والدول الاعضاء باضافه الحارس الثوري
وقوات التابعه له الى قائمه الارهاب بما
في ذلك قوات البسيج وفي القدس وقد نظم
الايرانيون ونشطاء من مونتريال وكالغاريا
وكندا مسيره طلبوا من خلالها بدعم المجتمع
الدولي للانتفاضه الدوليه للشعب الايراني
وعبر المشاركون في هذا التجمع عن تضامنهم
مع الشعب الايراني من خلال الاغاني
الثوريه وعرض صور القتلى من المتظاهرين
نشرت المتحدثه باسمي مركز المدافعين عن
حقوق الانسان في ايران نرجس محمد تقريرا
عن عنبر العام للنساء بسجن ايفين في طهران
محمديه وهي نفسها الان في السجن لفتت الى
ان هناك احدى و60 سجين في سجن ايفين وكشفت
في تقريرها تفاصيل عن ادانتهن وزجهن في
الانفرادي والاستجوابات وتشكيل ملفاتهن
القضائيه وكذلك اوضاع احتجازهم وحقهم في
الوصول الى خدمات العلاج تعكس شده قمع
السجينات من قبل النظام الايراني ووصفت
محمد حبس السجينات في الانفراد بانه
انتهاكم جسيم لحقوق الانسان واعمال تعذيب
يعانين نتيجه من عده مضاعفات صحيه مستريمه
وحول ذلك ينضم الينا في الاستوديو صالح
حميد باحث في الشان الايراني اهلا بك معنا
سيد صالح في استديوهات العربيه في الرياض
اذا محمد يتحدث عن القمع الذي يواجهناه في
السجون الايرانيه وهي ايضا سجينه الان كيف
تقرا المشهد ومردود الفعل الدوليه التي
يمكن ان تغير من الواقع المرير للسجينات
في ايران
في ايران يعني عدد كبير من ااا الناشطين
والصحفيين والمثقفين يلاقبه النشطاء
بجامعه اذن لاحتوائها على عدد كبير من
طلبه الجامعات حتى ساتذه بينهم
وهمم ولذلك هذه الممارسات
تشتد ضد السجناء وخاصه السجنات النساء كل
ما تحدث همم احتجاجات وهذه الموجه من
القمع وهذه الموجه من الضغوط تاتي بعد
الاعدامات ضد
المتظاهرين العاديين الذين اعتقلوا همم في
خلال مظاهرات اربعه اشهر الاخيره الان
يبدو ان الدور وصل على
الناشطات والصحفيين اللي بهدف اسكات اي
اصوات تعكس هذه المعاناه لكن بالطبع هناك
دائما شخصيات شجاعه مثل همم نرجس محمد
واخرين يكشفون عما يحدث في داخل السجون
السيد صالح يعني محاولات هذه لم تنجح مع
محمد يعني خرجت وتحدثت في تقرير مفصل ماذا
نتوقع ان يحدث لها الان بعد ما تحدثت وهي
في السجن الان
هي منذ عشر سنوات هذا الوضع يعني همم لعده
سنوات يتم الافراج عنها لاسباب مرضيه
وتعاد مره اخرى الى السجن وهمم لا تستطيع
السلطاتها في الواقع الان حتى
صحفيات همم فرح حامد والها محمد وهما اول
من نشر عن كيفيه مقتل امين في هذا السجن
نفسه فقط لمجرد اداء عمله الصحفي ونشر
تقارير حول كيفيه مقتل امين همم يعني
النظام لا يستطيع همم
على الامور يحاول همم من خلال المزيد من
الضغوط من خلال حرمان هؤلاء سجينات مثل
نرجس محمد وغيرها من تلقي العلاج ومن
تناول ادويه وهن ان يجبرهن على السكوت لكن
هذه المحاولات كلها لم تعدد فعل دوليه
اكثر الشده سيد صالح ولكن يبدو ان ردود
الفعل الدوليه لا تكترث لها ايران يعني
رئيس البرلمان الايراني يهدد بتصنيف
الجيوش الاوروبيه كمنظمات ارهابيه ما ان
تم تصنيف الحارس الثوري الايراني
تصريحات للاستهلاك المحلي و الادعاء يعني
اليوم هناك جلسه سريه في البرلمان مع قائد
الحرس الثوري لمناقشه كيفيه الرد على قرار
البرلمان الاوروبي يوم غد الاثنين هناك
اجتماع هام للاتحاد الاوروبي همم لكن لا
تزال هناك همم انقسامات حول تصنيف الحرس
الثوري كله برمته كمن ارهابيه او فرض حزم
جديده من العقوبات على الحرس الثوري هناك
مشروع حسب المعلومات التي تلقيناها تتبناه
هولندا والمانيا لتصنيف الحرس الثوري
المنظم الارهابيه لكن هناك بعض المعارضه
داخل همم دول الاتحاد طبعا الحرس الثوري
اليوم ايضا هدد بانه سيصنف الجيوش
الاوروبيه كما منظمات ارهابيه لكن هذه
التهديدات لا اعتقد انها همم ايران تستطيع
تطبيقها همم في عام 2019 تذكر الرئيس
الامريكي السابق لدوله ترامب صنف الحرس
منظمه الارهابيه وايضا هددت ايران بان
ستضرب بالقوات الامريكيه في 2020 هددت
ايران بانها سترد على مقتل سليماني
باستهداف القوات الامريكيه اغتيال
المسؤولين الامريكيين لم ينفذ اي من هذه
الوعود لانه القوه التي لدى الى تستخدمها
ضد شعبها فقط القمح في همم الشوارع او ضد
دول المنطقه من خلال تغذيه المليشيات
الاموال والسلاح وتدريبها والاشراف عليها
لذلك هذه الضغوط وهذا التحرك الاستنفار من
في الداخل الايراني يعكس اهميه ومدى قوه
هذه العقوبات وايضا همم القرار المهم اذا
ما تم يوم غد بتصنيف الحرس الثوري منظمه
ارهابيه شكرا لك لوجودك معنا في الاستديو
صالح حميد باحث في الشان الايراني
كشفت مصادر عراقيه موثوقه ان انتهاء بطوله
خليجي 25 كان ساعه صفر لتنفيذ خطه لاحداث
تغيير في الحكومه العراقيه يصلوا الى درجه
اسقاطها تقودها حساب الشيعيه متضرره من
القيود الامريكيه على بيع الدولار وفقه
صحيفه الشرق الاوسط لكنها اشارت الى ان
عوامل اقليميه وتوازن القوى العراقيه
احبطها او احبط الخطه مؤقتا المصادر
شيعيه تدير شبكات مصاريف تستخدمها لغسل
الاموال لصالح جهاد خارجيه بدات تشعر بان
سياسه الحكومه الحاليه تهدد مصالحها
واستغياب المصريين متوقع يجتمع وزراء
خارجيه الدول العربيه اليوم في العاصمه
الليبيه طرابلس في لقاء عرضته الحكومه
المكلفه من مجلس النواب بقياده فتحي باشا
واعتبرته مخالفا لاجراءاته وقوانين
الجامعه العربيه ويجري او يجري هذا
الاجتماع الذي دعت حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
المنتهيه ولايتها بقياده عبد الحميد
الدبابه الى عقده في ظل اجراءات الامنيه
مشدده في ما لم تحدد الحكومه الملفات
المطروحه على طويله نقاشه وزراء الخارجيه
العرب كما لم يتم تاكيد مشاركه كافه
الوزراء في سيادته يعتبرت وزاره الخارجيه
بحكومه فتحي باشا ان الاجتماع
داخلي في الدوره 158 للجامعه ينص على
تكليف الامانه العامه باعداد دراسه
قانونيه حول صلاحيه تراوس الجلسه المشار
اليها وحول ذلك ينضم الينا من طرابلس
مراسل العربيه منير الاشهب اهلا بك معنا
منير
امن الحضور حتى الان من الغائب وما ابرز
ما على طاوله همم الحوار
اهلا بك فاطمه نعم الوصول الى هذه الساعه
الى هذه اللحظات فقط وصل وزير الخارجيه
التونسي الى طرابلس من حوالي نصف ساعه او
اكثر بقليل الى العاصمه طرابلس عبر مطار
نتيجه قادما من تونس هذا هو الحضور الرسمي
حتى الان المؤتمر او الاجتماع من المفترض
ان يبدا حسب جدول الاعمال الموزع او
البرتقال الموزع على الصحفيين ان يبدا بعد
حوالي ساعه من الان ايضا هناك حديث عن
وصول بعض الشخصيات او بعض ال- ال-
المندوبين الدول الى طرابلس ولكن ليس هناك
صح من وزاره الخارجيه الليبيه حتى الان
ليست هناك معلومات رسميه عن عدد الحضور
والتمثيل الدبلوماسي الحديث همم يعني هو
التصريحات من الخارجيه المصريه او مصدر
دبلوماسي يوم امس من الخارجيه المصريه في
عدم وجود تمثيل مصري في هذا الاجتماع ايضا
هناك الحديث عن غياب بعض الدول ولكن لم
يتاكد الامر الى الان الاجتماعي يجري وس
اجراءات امنيه مشدده داخل العاصمه طرابلس
الانتشار امني للقوات النظاميه قوات
الشرطه وحتى الاجهزه الامنيه الاخرى هنا
في طرابلس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه قد عطلت
العمل في بلديات طرابلس الكبرى بالكامل من
اجل الانتشار المشدد على ما يبدو منير هل
لنا ان نرى الصوره من خلفك
لا نحن الان داخل الفندق الخاص همم العقد
الاجتماعي هنا الامور العاديه انما
افريقيا خارج الطرقات تم اغلاق الطرق بيار
رسمي من مديريه الامن هنا في طرابلس
لاغلاق الطرق من المطار حتى وصولا الى
الفندق فقط
نعم فاطمه تم اعطاء اليوم يوم اجازه داخل
العاصمه طرابلس تجنبا لحدوث ازدحام او
عرقله في السير او عرقله الوفود القادمه
الى طرابلسا هو الاجتماع الاول من نوعه
الوزراء الخارجيه العرب منذ فتره طويله
هنا في طرابلس ولكن على ما يبدو ان تاخر
وصول بعض الوصول سيؤخر انطلاق هذا المؤتمر
ساعات اخرى او حتى يعني تعطيلها الى
المساجد لم تصل هذه الوفود ولكن حسب ما
افادتنا به بعض المصادر من وزاره الخارجيه
هناك بعض التاكيدات من بعض الدول حول
وصولها ليس هناك يعني جدول اعمال واضح همم
في بنده فقط كلمات سقطت لكل يعني الحاضرين
من اجل الخروج بتوصيات وتقديمه الى
الجامعه العربيه بصفه ان وزاره الخارجيه
هنا في ليبيا تتراس هذه الدوره وجاء هذا
الاجتماع بناء على هذا النظام ان من حق
ليبيا ان تستضيف يعني اجتماع دوري تشاوري
لوزاره الخارجيه العرب او حتى من يمثلهم
جنوب عنهم فاطمه نقف نحن في انتظار يعني
من سيصل همم الى هذا المكان بعد قليل حتى
نعرف من يعني سيحضر ومن اي سيكون غائبا
ولكن لربما الحديث الاكبر هو عن غياب مصر
في حضورها لمثل هذه الاجتماعات في في
طرابلس بالتحديد نعم خاتمه شكرا لك من
طرابلس مراسل العربيه منير الاشهاب نقلت
وسائل الاعلام من سوريا محليه انباء عن
مقتل 10 اشخاص بانهياري مبنى بحي الشيخ
مقصود في حلب وعن فقدان 30 شخصا على الاقل
تحت انقاذ المبنى المنهار واوضحت وسائل
الاعلام السوريه ان المبنى المنهار والشيخ
مقصود في حلب
نازحين من عفرين
بدات المليشيات الحوثيه في اليمن ومنذ
اسبوعين في اخضائي مئات الاشخاص من منتسب
الكيانات المجتمعيه في عموم المدن
والمناطق تحت سيطرتها لتلقي دورات تعبويه
وطائفيه وكذلك تدريبهم على طرق واليات
الضغط على السكان في مناطقهم لاجبارهم على
المشاركه قصرا في المبادرات وتقديم الدعم
المالي لها وقالت مصادر للشرق الاوسط ان
قاده الجماعه فيما تسمى الدائره
الاجتماعيه افضل تعليمات تحط على اخداع
الكائنات المجتمعيه التعاونيه جميعها
لدورات تعبئه من اجل ضمان ولائهم
للمليشيات والاشراف على الاموال التي
يجمعها السكان كما اقدمه الميليشيات
الحوثيه على التنكيل بسكان عدد من القرى
في مديريه همدان شمال صنعاء حيث قامت
عناصرها بمداهمه منازل السكان واستول على
الاراضي واختطفوا نحو 18 مدنيا وسط البنات
حقوقيه ومطالب للمجتمع الدولي بوقف
انتهاكات الحوتي وفي هذا السياق طالب
المركز الامريكي للعداله ومنظمه يمنيه
حقوقيه تعمل من داخل الولايات المتحده
طلبت بوقف الانتهاكات المتواصله بحق
السكان في مديريه حمدان متهما الميليشيات
بانها داهمه القرى وجرفت المزارع واحتلت
المنازل وطردت السكان تقرير جديد يلقي
الضوء على انتهاكات مليشيات الحوثي ضد
المهاجرين الافارقه وكيف يقومون باجبارهم
على قتال اليمنيين وبعكس ذلك يعملون على
معاقبتهم السلوك الحوثي وسطوه المليشيات
حولت حياه اللاجئين القادمين من افريقيا
الى جحيم
هربوا مما هو مر الى ما هو امر مهاجرون من
منطقه القرن الافريقي من اثيوبيا والصومال
قطعوا مضيق باب المندب الى اليمن وكلهم
امل في ان يجد الامان لكنهم لم يواجهوا
غير القسوه والغدر
ميليشيات الحوثي في الحرب لقتل اليمنيين
واذا رفضوا تلقوا اشد العقوبات
ما نشتيش قاتل اذا اشتري قاتل نحنا
ببلادنا من زمان
وطلبنا احنا اخواننا اليمنيين الامان وطلب
لغمه وكذا
[موسيقى]
المهاجرين تفوقوا ايه تصور بل هي اقرب
لممارسات النازيين
الحوثيين
سواء كان المهاجرين الشرعيه
قامت كان في هناك محرقه عملتها مليشيات
الحوثي هذه المحرقه عنها مقتل المئات
وحريق يعني عدد كبير من هنا الى الافارقه
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره التابعه للامم
المتحده سجلت وصول اكثر من
73.000 مهاجرين افريقي الى اليمن خلال
العام الماضي ياتون الى اليمني ليتمكنوا
من تقديم طلبات الهجره او اللجوء من خلال
الس الاجنبيه والمنظمات الانسانيه
لكنهم لا يجدون الاضطهاد والعنف والتجنيد
القصري من قبل ميليشيات الحوثي العربيه
رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه وترقب لاقاله
اريا درع اليوم
ادومه الروسيه اوكرانيا باسلحه الهجوميه
ويؤكد انه سيؤدي لكارثه عالميه
برلمان وايران يقول انه سيعتبر جيوش
اوروبا منظمات ارهابيه ردا على اي تصنيف
للحرس الثوري
في ظل اجراءات الامنيه مشدده الدبيبه يعقد
اجتماعا لوزراء الخارجيه العرب ومصر تتغيب
الاف المحتاجين يتظاهرون ضد الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وقرارات وزاريه مرتبه استجابه
للضغوط
توقعت وسائل اعلام من الاسرائيليه ان رئيس
الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو سيقيل رئيس حزب
شاس اريا درعي من منصبه كوزير في الحكومه
خلال جلسه اليوم امتثالا لقرار المحكمه
العليا في اسرائيل والتي ابطلت تعيين درعي
بسبب عدم اهليته القانونيه على خلفيه
ادانته بجرائم تهرب ضريبي التي ذلك تزامنا
مع تظاهر عشرات الالاف في شوارع تل ابيب
احتجاجا على سياسه رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو مشاركه في
التظاهرات التي انطلقت من وسط تل ابيب
زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يائير الذي اكد
في وقت سابق انه سيتواجد في التظاهرات
تمديدا بسياسه حكومه نتنياهو
عشرات الالاف يهدفون ديمقراطيه
ويتظاهرون مجددا من هنا من وسط شوارع
مدينه تل ابيب ضد خطه الحكومه برئاسه
باليمينه ياهم لتنفيذ التغييرات جذريه في
القضاء والتي من شانها ان تحدها من سلطات
محكمه العدل العليا
مظاهره ستكون فقط البدايه لسلسله مظاهره
حسب تعبير احدى المنظمات المسؤوله عن
تنظيمها في ظل تخوف الحكومه لتحول
المظاهرات الى سما مات داخليه اكبر واصيان
مدنيا محتمل لا نقول غاصي من تل ابيب
العربيه
[موسيقى]
قال المحامي الشخصي للرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن بوب انمو حقيقي وزاره العدل اعثر
على ستي وثائق سريه اضافيه خلال عمليه
تفتيش منزل في
ولايه واوضح باور في بيان رسمي انه خلال
عمليه البحث التي استغرقت قرابه اثنتي
عشره ساعه سحورت وزاره العدل على المواد
التي اعتبرتها ضمن نطاق تحقيقها بما في
ذلك ستي وثائق سريه تعود للفتره التي كان
يشغل فيها بيض منصبه نائبه الرئيس
نشرت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه
تقريبا كشفت فيه ان رئيس موظفين البيت
الابيض
يتنحى قريبا تزامنا مع التحقيق بيضا
الصحيفه وصفت الاستقاله المرتقبه بانها
اهم تغيير في اداره الرئيس الامريكي منذ
تولي مايدي منصبه قبل عامين
مع التحقيق بوقائق بيض السريه
صحيفه نيويورك
كشفت ان مغادره ارون بلاي قد تاتي بعد
خطاب بيض المقرر في السابع من فبراير
الصحيفه وصفت الاستقاله المرتقبه بانها
اهم تغيير في اداره بيضا منذ توليه
الرئاسه قبل عامين
قالوا ان البحث جار عن بديل ومن المحتمل
ان يستمر كلين لفتره الانتقاليه
تاتي المغادره ايضا في وقت يواجه البيت
الابيض مجموعه واسعه من التهديدات
السياسيه والقانونيه
عن مقتل 10 اشخاص واسافر اصابه 9 اخرين في
اطلاق نار بحديقه في كاليفورنيا اذا اطلاق
نار في كاليفورنيا ادى الى مقتل 10 اشخاص
واصابه تسعه اخرين اذا نذكر بالعجل الذي
ولدنا قبل قليل حيث هناك اطلاق نار يحدث
في حديقه في كاليفورنيا ادى الى مقتل 10
اشخاص واصابه تسعه اخرين ويبدو ان هذه
الصور مباشره تريدون الان او قبل قليل عن
هذه الحادثه التي حدثت في حديقه ما في
كاليفورنيا وادت الى مقتل 10 اشخاص واصابه
9 اخرين يبدو ان المصابين ينقلون الى
سيارات الاسعاف الان بعد هذه الحادثه لا
تفاصيل الان حول من همم المطلق النار وما
تفاصيل هذه الحادثه ولكن سنوافيكم بها همم
تريدين
وفي عوده الى سياق نشرتنا اشار موقع
1945 الامريكي الى استمراريه تاثير ترامب
داخل الحياه السياسيه في الولايات المتحده
مستندا في ذلك على عده اسباب من بينها
استطلاع راي اجرته مؤسسه مورنينج كونسلت
[موسيقى]
قصر بيكنجهام اعلنا انه سيتم الاحتفال
بتتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث لمده ثلاثه
ايام بدا من السادس من مايو المقبل بمواكب
تقليديه وحفل موسيقي في قلعه ويستر يعد
هذا التتويج الحدث الرئيسي للعائله الملكه
البريطانيه خلال عام 2023 وسيكون اليوم
الثامن من مايو يوم اجازه للبريطانيين
احتفالا بهذه المناسبه وسيتمكنون من
مشاهدات الاحتفالات بالاضافه الى مشاهده
اضاءه المباني الشهيره باشعه الليزر وعروض
بطائرات مسيره اعلن رائد الفضاء الامريكي
الشهير باز اودرينا الذي شارك في بعثه
ثاني انسان قدمه سطح القمر اعلنا زواجه
بمناسبه عيد ميلاده الثالث والتسعين
هو الوحيد الذي لا يزال على قيد الحياه من
بعثه
ااا اليفن او بولو اليفين عفوا التي اصبح
خلالها معنى الام سترونج اول انسانين وطات
اقدامهما سطح القمر في 20 يونيو
مشاهدين اعداد المشردين يتزايد والاشخاص
من دون ماوى في العاصمه الخرطوم الى
مستويات عاليه
رصدت معاناه المشردين وادمان عدد منهم على
انواع من المخدرات بينهم اطفال
صابر طفل لم يرى العالم كبقيه الاطفال
هرب من منزله من احدى الولايات السودانيه
متجهه الى الخرطوم لان والده السمراء ضربه
بعد وفاه والدته فلجا الى الشارع
يلا هتبطلي اشرطه
المشردون في الخرطوم الفقر هو السبب الذي
قذف به من الشارع لكنه ليس الوحيد هناك
مشكلات اجتماعيه وصحيه ظل تحيط بهم الى ان
وصلوا الى هنا كيف يعيشون وماذا يفعلون
وهل يشكلون خطرا على المجتمع
بعض الشباب
[موسيقى]
يجمعهم الشارع يتشابهون في القصص يختلفون
في الاعمار وعمق الماسيسي يقولون ان
الدمعه تروي الكثيره من قساوه الحياه اما
هنا وسط هؤلاء فان البسمه هي البديل بسمه
لا مناسبه لها بلغه المنطق
قد يزداد
لهم المتسخ وحياتهم التي لا تشبه حياه
الناس لكن ما نلقادر على تعليمهم او
انتشالهم من هذا المستنقع مستنقع الفقر
والجوع والذل والظلم مرتين ظلم الظروف
والمجتمع اول حاجه بياثر عليه امن المجتمع
لانه ممكن المتشردين يكون عرضه
للمخاطر من تجار البشر من ترويه المخدرات
للاهتداءات العنف وممكن همزاتهم يكون
عنيفين ممكن يشاركوا في اي حاجه غير
قانونيه يتناسب منها المجتمع العربيه
[موسيقى]
من الخرطوم الى بكين حيث قال رئيس المركز
الصيني لمكافحه الامراض والوقايه منها ان
احتماليه عوده تفشي وباء كورونا خلال
الشهرين او الثلاثه القادمه قليله جدا
ومخوف من موجه تفش جديده لفيروس كورونا
يبددها مسؤولون الصينيون كبير خبراء
الاوبئه في المركز الصيني لمكافحه الامراض
والوقايه منها كان اخر المطمئنين في هذا
الشان دون التهويل من تداعيات حركه التنقل
الضخمه الجاريه في البلاد
حركه التنقل الضخمه خلال فتره عطله السنه
القمريه الجديده يحتمل ان تعمل على انتشار
الوباء ما يفاقم العدوى في بعض المناطق
ولكن ليس من المرجح حدوث موجه جديده من
كوفد 19 على المدى القريب
حصانه المناعه الجماعيه من فيروس كورونا
تحول سكان الصين من مواجهه موجه تفش ثانيه
فوفقا للمركز الصيني لمكافحه الامراض اصيب
نحو 80% من المواطنين لكنها حصانه مؤقته
قد تستمر لمده ثلاثه اشهر
وفي ما يتوافد الصينيون على محطه السكك
الحديديه والمطارات للتوجه الى مناطق
بمناسبه عطله راس السنه القمريه حضر
الرئيس شيجن بيج من عدم جاهزيه المناطق
ريفيه للتعامل مع تطورات الفيروس
لابد من بدل المزيد من الجهود لتحسين
رعايه الطبيه للفئات المعرضه للاصابه
بالفيروس في المناطق الريفيه ومعالجه
نواقص في الوقايه من الاوبئه في هذه
المناطق
اما البيانات الرسميه الاخيره فاشارت الى
وفات نحو ستين الف مواطن صيني بسبب كورونا
على مدار شهر حتى الثاني عشر من يناير
الجاري الامر الذي يضع الوضع الصحي في
الصين تحت مجهر الترقب خاصه بعد التخلي عن
سياسه صفر كوفد الصارمه علي السمان
العربيه
باسلحه الهجوميه ويؤكد انه سيؤدي لكارثه
عالميه
برلمان ايران يقول انه سيعتبر جيوش اوروبا
منظمات ارهابيه الرادادا على اي تصنيف
للحرس الثوري
في ظل اجراءات امنيه مشدده الدبابه يعقل
اجتماعا لوزراء الخارجيه العرب ومصر تتغيب
في امان الله
[موسيقى]